you can see that this is going to be a
multi-stage of it right well it's a
multi multi stage event obviously
several balls are chosen but some of
them are blue red on which there's one
rule that operates okay and then some of
them would be white on which another
will operate does that make sense so in
order to be able to do something with
this I need to know how many will be
blue red and how many will be what okay
now just look look the previous part of
the question part two is trying to nudge
you in a direction it says n minus our
balls are white have a look at part 1
our balls are blue red if you take that
many blue red and that mean why you put
them together and you'll have and in
total does that make sense so what I'm
going to say if any of them are chosen
let ah right be blue red which means the
remainder that's in take away our at
what
okay now remember you want to pick these
and those these and those so how am I
going to combine these together these
numbers right the number of ways
together i have to multiply right
because I've got to do these on and I've
got to do these buttons this number here
the number of ways is just our plus one
where's right and then over here this is
NCR where's you with me so far okay so
what I've got here is the total number
of ways with remember I've defined our
blue red 2 u is equal to okay this is
how many going to do one part first aid
/ r plus 1 and then this is how many you
got to do for the white ones second
stage oh okay so you look at that and
you think okay well that's true but it's
not what they were asking me to do right
what am I missing what I miss you
let's put a value on hand right let's
suppose hands fine okay the dev we chose
for our was on three right that was the
one I choked so suppose this is three so
much for watching The Killing Joke okay
um you know five your three how many
white right okay now here's one way of
doing this right and under this scheme
there's lots of different ways to get a
different configuration okay but who
said there had to be free or red how
many other ones could them in there can
be fourth or two or five or one or zero
right any number of options right so
what I need is all of them I need all of
them if only I had a way of adding up
turns where I need all of the whole
numbers oh wait I do it's called if I
got there it's called Sigma notation
right you see this okay so what I'm
going to do is I've got this is the
number of ways with our blue and red ok
so now with the total ways with any
number of you already okay
so I need to add up a whole bunch of
these with different values of ah ok so
I'm going to add up what's the smallest
number of blue red that I could have
Sarah I don't have to choose anything
they could all be white that's fine
what's the largest number of blue great
i could choose and their n balls being
chosen right so i can choose n and that
means there will be nothing to be why
does that make sense right because this
will be n and that'll be n minus n which
is 0 right something going all the way
up to em and then this is what I'm
adding up each time like so ok now look
at what you got and look at where you've
got to get to see where you've got to
get to what am I gonna have to do with
this thing cuz I can't work with it
right now it's not what I'm ok yeah i've
got all these earlier parts that i can
use for instance i mean i robbed one of
them off but i can use this right see
this where is that in there you see it
hiding it's going to help if I break
this into pieces right there's the piece
that has the are lots of this does that
look familiar and then there's the piece
which has the one lot of this that ok
yep so this is this is one more thing
ariat now the sum of the zones is the
sum of the songs ok that was lucky as
you want I'm going to break these two
apart this is a segmentation and
deciding upon refer to these and a whole
bunch of these striking regardless
separately you'll see why this is
important in a second this is our NC oh
and then there's just NCR ok I'll look
carefully don't miss any details let's
have it got this one first do we know
what this is equal to
look look you've just been doing this
question for like half an hour this is
to the power of man right we know that I
mean it's kind of an important identity
but we also proved it in Part B Part 1
right puppy power yeah what about this
guy do I have a value that looks exactly
like that ah of one not quite i'm so
very close but i'm not quiet cuz look
you're like ah 0 you're not supposed to
be 0y you do that for okay but that's
alright that's okay i just have to take
off the 0 term and then I'll be left
with the 1 2 3 4 5 up to em does that
make sense so I'm going to pull up yet
no it's okay I know what the 02 is
giving me but I need to prove it this
improved question okay so therefore I
don't need a lot more space I reckon
just do it from this line I'm going to
break apart just like I broke about this
Sigma notation in 22 I'm going to break
apart this just live with factorials I'm
going to peel off the first one all the
biggest one right I'm so I'm going to
say here is the 0 term it's 0nc0 that's
the zero turn right and then what I'm
left with is from 1 up to n is that make
sense took it off the front of our NCR
are this this I can do with plus this
other segmentation that we already have
worked out what to do okay pretty much
there let's evaluate the way first time
first time first term is 0 right this
guy here is the N or is it on
and to them but it's what would I this
guy was you think they're too ok now
just having a look at where I'm supposed
to be going the result of your quiet and
you'll get this from your like that's
all in the right form I've got to have
their minus 1 power so to do that I'm
gonna take out a min or two right so
this is n lots of this and then if i
take it to out there will be 2 n minus 1
no now you're part of the tipsy yeah
that's right it's a big deal ok so let's
just stop for a moment window what made
this question challenging because there
were lots of things that made this
question John go back to lv director
Part B for a second what was hired at
Pompeii yep just pop it it wasn't as
hard but tell me what was no no because
i've defined some to be blue red because
it's one way of is one scheme that works
for those and there's another skin that
works for the white ones so if i know
that there are that are blue red then I
already know that there are n minus I'll
go to why I don't have to say that as
well ok so it's just like saying oh if
there are three blue I don't need to
tell you how I read there are that's
implied ok so i don't have to work that
out as a separate thing in fact if you
do you walk over count so it's like I've
done them I've done with that that
already defines how many white ones I
thought oh god I say I think they'll
only hard thing in Part B was really
just recognizing our differentiate ok
and then it falls out pudsey was
obviously much more difficult um what
strategies that I did I use that made it
click for you okay number one but i just
drew things i just drew things and a lot
our pattern i can see through what
really matters I'm not just gonna kind
of widely do it ah i know i'm going to
choose
that many and I've got to choose that
many good luck getting a plus one out of
that right um I saw from the picture how
I could say oh okay what really matters
and therefore this is the setting
details and then when you got to like
say part 3 what did I keep on saying as
I went through this I kept on bein yeah
use the previous pilots kind of look at
where you're headed alright if you keep
your if you keep one away from where you
came from and one hour you're headed
you'll be fine like these these steps
don't come out of nowhere feel like arm
or live bodies that result have a little
year and I've got to change this form so
that I can break apart these Sigma
notation because otherwise I can't use
these substitutions from the earlier
parts that make sense